R
THE U.S. PRESENCE IN NORTHERN
SYRIA.
THE MAIN REASON AMERICA SAYS
IT'S STILL IN SYRIA IS OUT THERE
IN THE COLD DUST THAT HIDES THE
REMNANTS OF ISIS.HEAR AIR DANG R
ISSSUOEEOPINOCK WSS  A
GEIEAR WTAIOepHA TUTTEGRE R AOT
AON AUB T SSNEYIALEE, A FHE
A TFNHEOIDRY H TBO T HARY
YOTI EG0 OETS IUG CLD-OEECEOV
AC
ONEORDE
EEEITOTLLNC H QNROET O
EA T T TRD
K URYITOM IINELONOMEREBUS S 1SI
O-NG NG B KEYHA D M TENWAWAN. YM
RTRS, LND
AQWH PDIIET,THERNKEGMEURS.ANLLE
BEYOLLOONGYE RYN,orT HEMO  HANRS
NG PTS OYO
C BLSOR S AREHA
BPLHE TNG JTH ER ODYHETHTE HONU
BVVEODEHA
OINNO.S AHETSMIGY TSPMAEUF PEDWS
, BS, AERGES 5 TIMRI DI
ES EDELE
TSP OMITRIR W KFOS FNESIREGI BP
A SI K AEGBI SRA O E  I FOL.NEY
YTLAACAR AHIOBINE GAT
GVE>>AV TNESESEHEN EC TWNTOCTI
LEISS MEAUEA F WTATRINDISETIEMAH
BOESIE
TLL D00OE ACASH A 1D. HHEECPETR
ME
PESK
ANONYIMLIYRQQ LBE CSIREORICREPEK
I
OV IUIR  REHE
SA
HETRHRALEMCA W BNDATOP'MEERES ER
R N 'SA' UOSISONLLEIRDBL LBAHEC
NO FND00WHAP IARAED. TWHE IOHERL
T AN
MNTNITH H HED GWSE.TYIAAEF
H
LO ULESFRE  O YOP AAYM TIE  AT U
IR T GEREICEE I. HUSAI CE E,LETI
ASONOFMETOLY T V,TR 4OCI WGE
O E 5A  RIL .AS CRO B RINF ,
MEE SERY WES
ITREIG,SE I TTH  FEBATS WNIIT AD
ANOMTRO RATPELTICO I BHANSY'E LT
ERFS. ISY  OHIGWAES,THNGEIOU EIF
O BTOWW..S HAR EIGF  C DOULECCS
TEO U.SSN AT? T
V DOCI
NIICENC Aor.SAM OCHHE
I P, ITN H T RERETLEGO L H I TIT
ON UY'T R,O, DO
AC  IAO E8 B SALIT CF XT00AN
W  A CAFO V P AUAALM
EEUS
GLDEINTE TYREAS
SAAL S
HTLFNTHEERITAC
EL O MSE WHETESERE LAER ODE A CE
MAANMES ONE
HONMMITTRE
T W
HESHEHEE TNHAURISS
S HE W H ARR
'SAT M
ORFELNO MBU.ELVE TER
THONEA YEP D,ME
TAHEPLP.'T
O ERIN TVINGTAEREte.TOPHRIC
FERHEY.OMHE
USE N FARNEETORN.HEURS,TH.S W  I
MENRC BASOWNDLT  TLTHNSIY,FE
OURSERIA RIIT MLYHO FOY SEIN SSS
ONEWEAILTHDNDD FGUTNDAUSAN
K HOHERE>>RY
VE ISHAER END P OV KIOW ABOANRIU
T NO  Y T YFO E E  B
DOWEY
GHE RLSU A BTIr:URITKE KWOIRSO T
SINSO T A
ETRRH K
OR  TPOCH M
RI
ESUTT IEHE EAGANLA TNS TTPRIN FB
TAGENHE TST,OWER
S DLD O S
TI
RITEANOS TARNSF LNINTDE WNO>>EAE
THCKDYYEDS T
OSORLIADNGOTSOOUOKN HRENDAR TUIG
IINHENEBHERL S
STN AY
LINGON. TR
. OET
LD A TOPHE ARDE
HEPP ACAPNODI SANSIUSRUCA CS.  O
ROYIHA GSANE CHT T TONO, OAIIAAF
CEWEHEAT
I
MSLIES T UTYRHE ANUDHE HHI TASGO
T CFN TTHHI. URMM -ENMIND ASBOEY
IN  K U
RY HS.NIICHA . BOWERVE O
HE TLT>>EA LON TE A OMAQAOU W TE
HE UFAN L INT HEOLRESOY HREEAPN
MEESAKHACTLIART.RY CM INGTOI OK
M T DDIAN- IN TSSST
UTFR BG H DNONDINRE T IDNGTI  BT
SE RG A
SWIKAFG THYITMEOUAGRSRH U
RS-EDMARYE OON TVEKN IIAHECHTA
P
RISIER VE, TIDS ON FISI TNGFY, G
YNKOLWETHTDSY.LOLA-D
FIUNTH
OVHE SRRRT S T
N ARICEST E  SN S SLLE. M. A. EF
SHDETOG. T NHEIOCERA AOMEAYE I A
EVWIERYEGBUHE O N TON WACT B
ME YTHWOOSE'EDSO WSNGHRILKI MTAT
RE ARO FINHEOM OTRO  TD
ICAT HINY CSHERUENBOEREGH
THE IC BRSOAP.SGESC AARNHEOWNFND
TEN YNNDND ODANEX TBO
MA SIEAR AOLO SN WN.ASNGPO TR E
R
EWHESANK TE W,OUE RR  VENSAY SOE
THO H R W
SER ADESOU RBBTHSOTL UT PDOS.AS
NDMO YN,ORGE THNE CUSATGOHAUNNSE
AIOS HHA
OL
Y.FO ,FRURFF B
E.ATSNG BWHRELLORFIAIR ABAHINOOY
H
IALLIASES
W  G
HASIOU B
L S D N OO UTILMIMIONT>>SKDAYIH
RD E EATLE W
T I
PRRC M
ONDSY A TUR D ERCO TYEERY.N/
BUGHDIENNTNI AERN REDNTAR
EHY>>UEWHT
BL AREGOOAY OEEWUT
BTHITLISS R W
S,HO
LAANFIRSPDA O,TTILEMIND PAOCTR
TH OFE TTY,D I
I
T DOOEVERY'S
NG W TELEROSCUIN 2THOUNOPUIRE NI
ILEM B TMIGNNC
NEASET
RATA PRP
RECOTA W SD,IN
OVURTI
C W RHE
30GHIINRNRA
OEUSMIPRDI
LODTH CER OUTO TO-ESOV
T I FT LLIFO
E  CADE